in the continent of Essos there are a
few religions growing faster than the
worship of the red God rule or a
dualistic religion of fire and pain and
life and ice and cold and death slave
children are often bought by the red
priesthood to service prostitutes or
warriors or priests in a dance to
dragons we are introduced to mokoro a
man would skin blackest pitch hair white
as ivory and a face shrouded in flame
mokoro is sent by the red priesthood as
a gift for Daenerys Targaryen supposedly
to offer guidance Tyrion encounters
mokoro while on a ship bound to Qarth
have you come to pray with me someone
told me the night was dark and full of
terrors what do you see in those flames
dragons dragons old and young true and
false bright and dark and you a small
man with a big shadow snarling in the
midst of it when the ship is hit by a
storm mokoro is presumed dead until of
course he shows up again on the ship of
Victarion Greyjoy where he gains
Victoria's Trust with the strange powers
and predictions but what are mokoros
true intentions is he truly loyal to
Victarion
or is the Greyjoy simply a pawn in
mokoros ultimate goal first we have to
decrypt some of mokoros prophecies
mokoro mentions to Tyrion that he sees
dragons true and false
this likely refers to Dany the true
dragon and egg on the false dragon he
also refers to Tyrion as a small man
with a big shadow this is not the first
time the Tyrians large shadow has been
drawn to our attention the first time
our author does this is Ana Jon Snow POV
chapter when he opened the door the
light from within through his shadow
clear across the yard and for just a
moment Tyrion Lannister stood as tall as
a king and again in a Clash of Kings
during Tyrians conversation with varies
on the abstract nature of power very
smiled here then power resides where men
believe it resides no more no less so
power is a mama's trick a shadow on the
wall there is murdered yet shadows can
kill and ofttimes a very small man can
cast a very large shadow
what mokoro seems to be implying here is
that Tyrion will be essential to events
to come his large shadow represents his
influence mokoro sees him snarling in
the midst of dragons casting a shadow
which implies that although Tyrion
influence it will not be something that
he desires more so something that is
forced upon him have you seen these
others in your fires
he asked wearily only their shadows
mokoro said one most of all at all and
twisted thing with one black eye in ten
long arms sailing on a sea of blood this
seems to refer to urine gradually the
crow's eye the sigil of house Greyjoy is
the Kraken at inland sea monster with
one enormous eye the fact that he sees
him sailing on a sea of blood says to me
that death shall follow the Kraken
wherever he goes
perhaps iske refer to Victarion as well
who we know mokoro has glimpsed also the
fact that mokoro sees the kraken shadow
most of all implies that the kraken will
be daenerys targaryen is greatest
adversary and since Victarion does
possess what is claimed to be a dragon
binder a horn that combined dragons to
its will this lends credibility to this
idea mokoro provides Victarion with much
useful information when he is saved from
the sea but there is one particular
prophecy that seems to stand out as
being more ominous and even Victarion
realizes you're drowned God is a demon
the black priest mackerel said
afterwards he is no more than a thrall
of the other the dark God whose name
must not be spoken take care
priest Victarion warned there are godly
men aboard the ship men who would tear
out your tongue for speaking such
blasphemies your red God will have his
due I swear it my word is iron ask any
of my men the black priest bowed his
head there is no need the Lord of Light
has shown me your worth Lord captain
every night in my fires I glimpse the
glory that awaits you
what glory is mokoro referring to here
what do shall the red God have of the
carrion there seems to be but one option
here fire and blood Victarion will die
and be given to the flames mcaro always
knew that Tyrion ship would not reach
Qarth he knew that he was bound for
slavers Bay his every action and every
word is careful and precise when mokoro
is found by Victarion ship the crew
wishes him to be put to death
mokoros calmness strikes fear into the
heart of the Ironborn
he tells Victarion that he knows of his
plan to seek out Daenerys Targaryen and
also that the carrion will die from the
wound on his arm without his help
through fire and magic mokoro heals
Victarion and his arm becomes as black
as mokoro skin but was it truly in
Victorians best interest to other red
priests feature prominently in our story
Melisandre and Thoros of Myr both of
them are sent to Westeros with orders
from the red priesthood Thor Rose was
sent to King's Landing to curry the
favor of the then fire obsessed Mad King
Aerys but the king was unimpressed by
his tricks Melisandre Skol however is
less clear in the beginning she believes
Stannis Baratheon to be azor Ahai reborn
but later seems to question this in
favor of Jon Snow I pray for a glimpse
of azor Ahai and real or shows me only
snow both Milla saundra and Thoros seem
to possess power that normal men do not
Milla saundra can use her Ruby to
glamour and perhaps even control people
in a dance of dragons when mance rayder
approaches Melisandre she can feel the
Rubies stir Melisandre felt the warmth
in the hollow of her throat as the
Rubies stirred at the closeness of its
slave here our author implies that mance
is bound to Milla Sandra's will because
of the Ruby could Victarion as well be
under the influence of a similar type of
magic in a dance with dragons mokoro
spends a great deal of time studying the
inscriptions on the dragon binder mokoro
tells Victarion that it translates to
I am Dragan binder no mortal men shall
sound me and live blood for fire fire
for blood who blows the hell horn
matters not the Dragons will come to the
horns master you must claim the horn
with blood which is exactly what mokoro
may do if Victarion is truly bound to
mokoros magic then is mokoro not truly
victorians master the master of the
master mokoro seeks the power of dragons
he will use the Kerrigan who has
foolishly fallen into his trap to gain
what he seeks but to what end power the
glory of the priesthood
the answer is unclear what is clear
however is that McCory does not have
Victorians best interest in mind he is
clearly hiding several crucial details
about his visions and he is not likely
translating all of the inscriptions on
the dragon binder it is possible that
Makarov used the Greyjoy's as a threat
and wants to neutralize the threat
so that Daenerys Targaryen will succeed
and it is also possible that mokoro
likes so many in our story six only
power for himself thank you guys for
watching make sure you like and
subscribe for more ideas of Ice and Fire
also check out my Twitter account for
updates on future videos